good morning John this video has
spoilers through the end of season 3 of
the good place the good place is a good
show about four not very good people who
have died and ended up in a very bizarre
afterlife through its first two seasons
the show explored really deep questions
many of the same ones we've been dealing
with as humans for thousands of years
but then in season 3 as the good place
is good at doing it swerves on yeah and
suddenly the show isn't about how to be
a good person it's about how to be a
good person in 2019 a mess y'all
spoilers in earnest now a bad place is
going to get all of them eventually even
your precious PP king dug for said in
season 3 we find out that everyone goes
to the bad place even the guy who knows
the rules and has been doing everything
he can his whole life the proposal here
is that the modern world is so messed up
you can't live in it without being a bad
person but most times a lot of points to
get to good place was 521 years ago this
is kind of a rough thing for me to hear
personally because like I kind of
believe it the bad place is I'm
tampering with points they don't have to
because every day the world gets a
little more complicated and being a good
person gets a little harder or more than
ten years one of the central themes of
this channel on YouTube has been to
engage with the complexity of the world
but if you do that what you find
isn't that everything's bad it's just
that nothing's all the way good the book
that you loved that was written by a
misogynist the terrible things done in
the name of your religion historical
atrocities that like all of society is
based on and that you may still benefit
from every beautiful genius expression
of human creativity and hard work has a
dark side there's this chicken sandwich
that if you eat it it means you hate gay
people now unlike Jason's friend big
noodle and I love the big noodle
allegory I'm the kind of guy who
actually has time to figure out whether
oat milk is better for the world than
almond milk it is what does better than
really mean what's the scale here how
bad am i if I choose to drink almond
milk because I like the taste better and
how much worse is that than like being
mean to a friend or like putting sprite
in my water cup at McDonald's good
places answer is the accounting
department beings who judge every action
you take and determine how many points
you get or lose anastasiya and they
stuff vegetable Department we call
Hector
in American coins and my dear buddy Matt
weird sex thing and if you don't hit a
threshold you go to the bad place the
math is cold objective and airtight
maybe it is in their universe but it is
not in ours
one thing the Internet has been really
good at for certain people is
highlighting all of the many ways
unintended harm can be done for others
oddly enough it's been really good at
insulating them from that it's almost as
if the internet amplifies your worldview
but for people who are open to the
complexity the reality of reality is
just way too complicated for the
accounting departments of our brains to
handle it's almost as if utilitarianism
relies on a hyper individualist
worldview that isn't reflective of
reality individuals make decisions I
will never say that's not the case there
are many decisions that are much harder
than others and that have much greater
costs associated with the themes of
season 3 quietly but geniusly highlights
that our current system of consumerism
fueled pop utilitarianism mostly isn't a
tool we're using to make the world a
better place it is instead a way to
rapidly and inaccurately judge the
goodness and badness of ourselves and
each other so here are four really
important things that I learned from
this very good content one not everyone
has the capacity to weigh every choice
they make and that does not make them
bad people - it is harder to be the kind
of person who seeks complex truths
rather than retreats into simple lies
but it is also better free morality
should only be one part of that
curiosity because if it is only about
morality then you only view the world
through the lens of judgment and number
four our accounting departments will
always be flawed and so we should not
judge ourselves or others as if they are
not John we are down to just two days of
Pizza miss I will see you tomorrow